let's stick with the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 we're gonna go next to our caller
from the 707 area code caller from 707
who's this oh wow hey this is John
hey John go ahead okay so I wanted to
ask you if you think that trumps
possible switch a position on the
military might have to do with the
current downfall with the economy or at
least the stock market no I don't think
so and here's why Trump doesn't
understand the connection between those
things so I don't think that that that's
the case so what your what John's
referring to for people who don't know
is that after two years even more than
that after just years of bragging about
how he would spend more on the military
how Obama's not spending enough we got a
grow grow grow spend spend spend
he gets more money for the military 25%
increase over the last two budget years
then earlier this week he talked about
how he spoke to Putin and and the
Chinese president and about how it's
crazy it's crazy how much we spend on
the military if there's any kind of
subterfuge John I think it could be and
this is I don't actually think Trump is
this smart but if I had to come up with
something it would be Trump recognizes
he might have to make a call at some
point soon about whether he's going to
defend Ukraine militarily if Russia's
aggressions continue and he could be
laying the groundwork to say listen we
spend too much on the military already
that's the only thing I can think of you
don't think he's uh he's caught wind of
because he loves a strong economy
he loves that you don't think he's
caught wind too somehow that you know
the big two dips in the last two days or
something like this why would what
evidence do we have that he would
attribute it to military spending though
uh I'm not sure if he would attribute it
to military spending I'm not sure if
he's truly actually believed in the
military spending to be to begin with
but it's uh like he said earlier it
seemed like during the g20 he may have
had a conversation with Putin who may or
may not be
influencing him to you know [ __ ] or
military you know that sounds like a
good idea coming yeah yeah I think that
that's much more likely than it has to
do with the I think that you were saying
the same thing now which is we have no
reason to think that Trump would think
if the stock market goes down
I should stop spending money on the
military or are you saying the opposite
that he that maybe the stock market went
down because he said that I just don't
know that I understand what your
argument is no I'm not making an
argument what I'm saying is I think that
if Putin were to come to trump and Putin
were to say hey you know what your
economy is not looking so hot you guys
are spending way too much military you
know that's the most likely scenario and
it might matter it would be exactly like
that but I did mention that it could be
just something Putin put in his head I
think that's that's a the most
reasonable scenario from from what we
know John thank you I appreciate the
call